We can't undo the lies we
had to tell girls.
That's just the way it is.
I'm Finn,
Finn Ahern,
Dennis's son.
How do we know that you are
what you say you are?
He's dangerous, Val.
You need to be very careful.
I knew my dad,
he wasn't a murderer.
Then who did it?
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
We need to stick together.
We give him nothing,
we tell him nothing.
You want some help?
Finn?
This feels personal.
Mom!
I'm sorry.
Go and get him!
Always been on the outside.
Outside looking in.
I want this.
I want you.
I’m doing this for my dad.
And I won't stop until I find
out what you did to him,
because I know it was you, Val.
It's always you.
From now on,
we'll tell each other the truth.